[Musique]
bienvenue sur ce nouveau stream
bienvenue sur ce nouveau live j'espère
que vous êtes prêt à parler de flamand
aujourd'hui j'avais envie de vous parler
d'une espèce de flamand bien
particulière parce qu'il faut savoir
qu'il y a plusieurs espèces de flamand
dans le monde il y en a pas qu'une seule
j'avais envie de vous parler de celle-ci
voilà donc ça ça s'appelle le flamand
nain euh faiconayas mineure pour ceux
qui ont envie du nom scientifique et
donc le Flam en un comme vous pouvez le
voir est caractérisé par une coloration
qui est finalement pas si rose que ça
mais un petit peu quand même en dessous
des ailes un bec un peu
rougeâtre très foncé mais quand même un
œil jaunâtre et des plumes noires sur
les ailes le reste du corps est
finalement assez blanc donc pour un
flamant j'appellerai pas vraiment ça un
flamand rose même si on a un petit peu
de rose dessus il est plus dans les dans
les tons blancs gris avec quelques
touches de rose à part peut-être pour
les pâtes voilà donc ça c'est le plus
petit des Flamands qui existent au monde
nous avons six espèces de Flamands dans
le monde celui-là c'est le plus petit
euh c'est pas très très grand hein ça
fait à peu près de 1 à 3 kg pour les les
plus
gros pour les plus gros oiseaux vraiment
3 kg c'est c'est pousser un peu
d'ailleurs c'est ils atteignent rarement
2,5
euh et puis on a une envergure d'à peu
près 1 m euh voilà donc c'est pas non
plus un flamant rose un flamant énorme
j'allais dire flamant rose mais c'est
pas un flamant rose c'est pas un flamant
énorme he c'est c'est un oiseau qui est
pas petit non plus mais c'est pas c'est
pas parmi les les plus grosses bêtes
qu'on connaît petit closeup sur sur les
ailes pour vous montrer un petit peu les
plumes quand il ouvre les ailes et ici
vous connaissez évidemment le
comportement des Flamands parce que
c'est c'est très connu on avait fait une
vidéo avec Julien d'ailleurs où où on
s'amusait un petit peu à comparer les
Flamands à au dinosaur de Jurassic Park
voilà effectivement il se déplacent en
coupou alors ceux-là ce sont c'est c'est
une des parades nuptiales parmi chez les
Flamands où en fait ils sont en groupe
comme ça et puis ils se baladent sur
l'eau en tournant la tête dans tous les
sens c'est c'est assez marrant à
regarder et donc ça c'est lapparade
nutiale donc chez les flamandes vous les
voyez tous en train d'essayer de lever
la tête le plus plus ha possible là en
écartant bien les plumes du coup pour
montrer qu'ils sont très gros très
imposants avec de jolies plumes et tout
par nups c'est c'est pas très compliqué
c'est facile à faire puis bah ça veut
peut-être vous avoir une une femelle si
vous y arrivez donc voilà pour le Flam
enin un petit oiseau ma fois fort
sympathique que j'avais envie de vous
présenter aujourd'hui alors ce petit
Flam en contrairement aux autres espèces
qu'on a vu dans notre petite émission I
du mardi qui était toutes des espèces en
voie d'extinction en voie de disparition
enfin bref qui était franchement mal
barré ben celui-là il est pas si mal
barré que ça il est classifié en near
threaten donc en gros c'est la
première le premier pas vers la
disparition en quelque sorte mais ça
veut dire qu'il est pas encore tout à
fait vraiment en
danger le le nombre de Flam en un
commence un peu à diminuer mais on n'est
pas non plus sur une situation critique
ça peut attendre quelques années c'est
pas un problème ils disparaîtront pas
tout de suite donc là c'est pas un
oiseau que vous allez voir disparaître
dans 10 ans c'est un truc qui
normalement si tout va bien devrait
rester en vie quand même pendant encore
de longues années donc on n'est pas trop
on on s'inquiète pas trop pour eux voilà
pour pour dire ça simplement et alors je
sais pas si vous en avez entendu parler
mais en gros il s'est passé quelque
chose euh en en 2019 un un petit
événement que j'avais envie de vous
raconter parce que parce qu'en
l'occurrence c'est un événement auquel
j'ai participé et j'en avais touché deux
mots quand j'étais parti sur la chaîne
de amgy il y a il y a pas longtemps et
j'avais expliqué vite fait ce qui
s'était passé sur au niveau de la
migration de ces espèces là mais j'avais
pas vraiment expliqué toute l'histoire
derrière parce qu'il y a une histoire
derrière et je pense qu'il est temps de
la raconter ça fait déjà quelques années
que ça s'est passé et euh et voilà il
est temps que le monde sache n'est-ce
pas non mais il est temps qu'on en parle
un peu est-ce qu'il y a les questions
jusqu' les f son rose carrément des
crevettes mais leurs crevettes sont
crues et pas cuites alors comment ça se
fait non ceuxl ils sont roses parce
qu'ils vont ce qu'on appelle des
canobactéries canobactéries qu'ils vont
utiliser pour faire des pigments
derrière les canobactéries elles-mêmes
ne sont non'ont pas des pigments roses
mais ce ce qu'ils vont consommer va être
utilisé comme précurseur pour faire des
pigments et les pigments roses vont
effectivement se retrouver dans leur
plume mais mais les canobactéries
elles-même en fait c'est c'est
canobactéries c'est des bactéries qui
sont ble vert en coloration c'est pas
rose voil mais mais ça mange aussi des
petits crustacés mais en l'occurrence
ceux-l c'est plus de lacianobactérique
qu'ils sont en train de manger donc
c'est un peu différent les margerites
comme les flamand si absorbent du rosé
elles deviennent rose du coup si on a
une colorant jaune dans les croquettes
en eau flamant qu on met de l'encre
jaune dans l'eau de margerine ça fait
des flammes en jaune alors c'est une
bonne hypothèse mais non c'est une bonne
question euh en fait si vous avez pas le
bon précurseur pour faire le pigment bah
du coup vous aurez pas le pigment
derrière qui va êtreoduit donc en
l'occurrence si vous mettez du jaune
c'est pas le bon précurseur pour le
pigment des Flamands rose donc bah ils
feront pas de pigment du tout et ils
seront blancs tout simplement
voilà donc il faut avoir quand même la
base alors généralement c'est de la
caroténoïde pour le rose chez les
animaux en l'occurrence c'est ce qui se
passe ici aussi mais enfin chez les
oiseaux en tous les cas mais mais on a
résolu le problème en zoo en leur
donnant des carottinoïes dans
l'alimentation ce qui fait que du coup
ils sont ils sont rouges rosés ils ont
la bonne couleur normalement et si vous
avez de l'alimentation aussi pour oiseau
en captivité genre des perroquets truc
comme ça vous avez aussi des suppléments
caroténoïdes dans l'alimentation pour
être sûr qu' regardent leur couleur le
jolie couleur habituelle voilà alors
pourquoi les Flamands qui sont aux EAU
ne sont pas en cage par les autres et ne
s'envolent pas et du coup pourquoi leurs
copain nigrateur les rejoinent pas au e
ah très bonne question ben en fait quand
vous avez un animal qui est pas en cage
généralement c'est que on a fait en
sorte qu'il ne s'envole pas alors d'une
man
d'une manière ou d'une
autre
c'est moi je trouve ça un peu barbare
mais après c'est c'est mon c'est mon
avis chacun chacun voit les choses à sa
manière évidemment mais en gros ils vont
couper un petit bout juste la dernière
partie de l'aile c'est pas c'est pas
grandchose c'est les derniers doigts en
fait si vous regardez au niveau
skelctique qui sont sur l'aile et qui
font qu' qu'il y a une partie des plumes
qui ne pousseront jamais sur l'aile dans
ces CASL je vous av avertirait les les
trucs auquels ils sont attachés et donc
ça veut dire que l'oiseau ne pourra pas
il pourra planer un peu mais il pourra
pas vraiment faire du vol battu donc en
l'occurrence bah vous aurez des oiseaux
qui seront incapables de partir migrer
et qui vont rester sur place
effectivement voilà euh c'est c'est une
des solutions et la raison pour laquelle
les autres Flamands ne les rejoignent
pas aux EAU c'est que c'est tout
simplement pas une zone de migration
peut-être qu'ils ont pas considéré cet
endroit-là comme un endroit pour la
migration voilà tout simplement
il pourrait tout à fait les rejoindre
dans les colonies hein mais à mon avis
c'est pas sur la route de migration tout
simplement ils les ont pas rejoint à
cause de ça si vous regardez les
Flamands en France il ne remontent
quasiment jamais au-dessus du sud de la
France pour une bonne raison c'est que
c'est pas leur zone de répartition
habituelle donc de toute façon ils
passeront pas par là pour leur migration
donc à mon avis ils ne rejoindront pas
les Flamands qui sont aux Eau de Paris
par exemple
voilà d'autres questions avant qu'on
commence non j'espère que les Wallons
seront pas jaloux que ça parle que de
flamand ici
oui par contre je parle pas la langue
non plus donc désolé hein
ok donc ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
embrayer je vais vous présenter un
endroit qui s'appelle Kimberly en
Afrique du Sud alors Kimberly c'est ça
euh c'est une que je vous mettre ça
correctement voilà
donc Kimberly c'est ça c'est une ville
minière qui est en Afrique du Sud
et c'est une ville minière qui va
notamment avoir un petit lac
artificiel juste là sur lequel on va
trouver ces
flamande sauf que ce ce lac artificiel
donc a été créé par l'homme évidemment
et c'est un lac qui bah qui n'était pas
là de base il y avait même pas de d'eau
de de courant ou quoi que ce soit c'est
vraiment un lac qui n'est même pas sur
une rivière ou quoi c'est un lac qui est
créé par les rejets des entreprises qui
y a autour de Kimberly et notamment des
mines qui vont rejeter l'eau là-dedans
une fois qu'elle a été filtrée
évidemment ils vont quand même la
nettoyer un petit peu avant de mer là
dedans et qui vont donc faire cette
grande réserve d'eau après grâce à à
toutes les eaux qu'ils évacuent faut
savoir que les industries minières ça
nécessite pas mal d'eau lors des des
de leur de leur recherche de de diamant
d'or ou de n'importe quoi et surtout
après du nettoyage et donc ça c'est
toute l'eau qui va être utilisée pour ça
qu'il vont rejeter derrière et qui ont
décidé de faire un lac avec parce que
bon finalement autant faire un lac hein
on pourrait en faire autre chose mais
c'est pas la peine autant que ça serve à
quelque chose et ce lac a donc été créé
avec une petite île au centre une petite
île en S que vous voyez juste là qui a
été spécialement créé pour accueillir
des colonies de d'oiseau et notamment
des colonies de Flam enin sur lesquelles
donc des des petites îles sur lesquelles
ils peuvent nicher et alors ça s'est pas
trop mal passé parce que sur ce lac
depuis quelques années on a vu arriver
enfin depuis 10 ans maintenant on a vu
arriver donc des colonies de flamands
qui ont migré depuis d'autres lacs dans
l'Afrique du Sud et un peu plus haut en
Afrique aussi pour venir s'installer euh
au campf dam donc c'est le nom du lac
sur lequel donc ils ont commencé à faire
des des de la repro et vraiment à
s'installer sur place donc on a vraiment
des colonies donc comme ici vous voyez
les images avec vraiment vraiment des
colonies vraiment beaucoup d'oiseaux on
a on a quand même un paquet de de
bestioles sur place
et je crois qu'on a est-ce qu'on a pas
un endroit ouais je sais pas si on les
voit nicher mais en gros il y a il y a
pas mal de d'oiseaux il y a pas mal de
de besestiols il y a pas que des
Flamands il y a plein d'autres oiseaux
et et c'est des endroits où vraiment les
oiseaux vont nicher vont vont se
reproduire et ça va permettre d'avoir
bah d'essayer de soutenir un peu
certaines espèces qui sont pas forcément
en très grande forme parfois en voie de
disparition pour les Flamands c'est pas
le cas mais pour d'autres espèces
aquatiques ça peut l'être donc voilà
c'était un lac c'est c'était un projet
qui finalement c'est c'est plutôt bien
déroulé et qui a eu des résultats plutôt
plutôt correct
euh faut savoir en plus que le lac il
contient beaucoup de cyanobactéries donc
qui sont la nourriture principale des
flammes en un des cyanobactéries qui
sont là parce que malgré le fait que les
entreprises nettoient plus ou moins
l'eau qu'il rejettent dans le lac ben en
fait ce qui se passe c'est que euh il
nettoi pas complètement donc on va avoir
des restes parfois d'eau desgûts qui
vont atterrir dans le lac des des des
trucs avec avec des restes dedans et et
ces restesl vont servir aux colonies de
canobactéries pour se développer encore
plus ce qui procure encore plus de
nourriture pour pour les Flamands donc
en fait c'est assez marrant euh là pour
le coup on a une histoire de pollution
qui normalement pour nous humains est
pas top parce que ça donne des eos qui
sont un peu un peu cradeau mais pour les
oiseaux et pour les colonies si no
bactéries dont ils se nourrissent et ben
finalement c'est plutôt une auè euh donc
on était vraiment sur sur une relation
plutôt plutôt bien partie entre la ville
de Kimberly saque artificielle et les
oiseaux qui nichaient dessus sauf que le
problème c'est que Al attendez que
mettre la photo un peu en plus grand
est-ce qu'on la voit bien ouais c'est
pas
super sauf que évidemment ça pouvait pas
duré et un jour la colonie de flamant
rose qui s'était posée pour la
reproduction en décembre avait fait ses
nid et avait je sais pas si vous
connaissez les nid des Flamands je
peut-être les mettre
ici ni
flamand en gros c'est voilà alors là
c'est pas les mêmes vraiment mais en
gros c'est une sorte de de monticule
comme
ça ici de de de terre sur lequel vous
allez poser votre unique œuf hein par
couple de flamand vous avez un œuf
généralement donc voilà
hop ici on voit bien c'est souvent un
seul ça dépend des espèces j'imagine en
tout cas pour les flamants c'est les
flamants nain c'est un parfois deux mais
c'est rare donc voilà euh sur ces ces
nid ici debout donc les Flamands vont
déposer leurs œufs ça va incuber pendant
un mois et quelqu et puis après
normalement vous avez l'éclosion et ça
en Afrique du Sud ça se passe en
décembre janvier c'est à peu près la
période à laquelle vous allez
avoir la construction des nid et puis
après l'éclosion des poussins
normalement mi-janvier fin janvier dans
ces eau là en fonction des températures
évidemment ce qui s'est passé lors de
cette saison de
reproduction c'est
que soudainement toute la colonie a
déserté le lac de campfers sauf qu'ils
ont déserté le lac mais en laissant les
œufs derrière parce que les petits ils
avaient pas encore éclos ou alors ils
allaient éclore 2 jours après je crois
mais ils avaient pas encore éclos là sur
le cou donc tout d'un coup tous les
Flamands se barrent il reste les nit
avec tous les œufs dedans et il y en
avait quand même un paquet parce que
vous avez vu les la quantité d'oiseau
qui avait sur le lac tout à l'heure que
je vous ai montré là on était sur à peu
près 3000 pour vous donner une idée ça
fait
beaucoup donc les parents barre il
laissent les œufs sur place et la raison
pour laquelle les parents barre c'est
que en fait les industries qui étaient
censé produire et relâcher de l'eau dans
le lac pour une raison X ou Y je ne sais
plus avait décidé bah qu'elle le ferait
plus et du coup le niveau du lac avait
baissé mais suffisamment pour qu'en fait
la la la quantité de canobactéries
disponibles dans les EAU baisse avec et
donc pour qu'elle ne soit plus
suffisante pour soutenir la population
complète de Flamans les Flamands ont
donc décidé de migrer n'ayant plus de
nourriture fallait bien qu'il trouvent
autre chose donc ils sont partis sur
d'autres lacs voisins un peu plus loin
bref ils ont laissé leurs œufs derrière
eux alors gros problème
évidemment les associations sur place se
mobilisent et les associations sur place
décident de collecter les œufs alors je
sais pas si vous voyez un petit peu
l'idée mais on est quand même sur 3000
ufs de flamand qui sont col sur place
dans une toute petite ville parce que
Kimberly c'est pas grand Kimberly c'est
tout petit c'est ça Kimberly c'est ça
c'est vraiment pas grand sur une petite
ville minière avec pas beaucoup de main
d'œuvre pas beaucoup de gens qui sont
dispos je crois qu'il y a un cabinet
vétérinaire qui du coup a aidé à
collecter les œufs et c'est tout fini
derrière
donc c'était un peu la galère ils se
sont retrouvés avec des tas d'ux qui
d'ailleurs ont commencé à éclore parce
que de jours après tous les eux ils
avaient éclos donc on a retrouvé 3000
petits flamands qu'il a fallu tous
nourrir à la seringue à la pipette en
bref cétait la cata et qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont fait bah ils ont demandé de l'aide
alors voilà ça c'est certains des
articles qui ont été qui ont sont parus
à l'époque c'était en 2019 et donc ça ça
a été publié dans pas mal de journaux à
droite et à gauche et vous aviez quand
même pas mal de voilà de médias qui sont
parés de l'affaire et qu'on qu'on essayé
d' expliquer l'affaire à tout le monde
et là ce que vous voyez ici donc ça
c'est les images de campferdam mais là
en dessous ce que vous voyez c'est en
fait un zoo en l'occurrence ça c'était
un aquarium plus qu'un zoo qui a
notamment commencé à aider et récupérer
des des poussins pour les éleverés
eux-mêmes donc dans ces
cas-là les les associations qui avaient
collecté les œufs ont décidé de faire
appel bah au gouvernement sud-africain
gouvernement sud-africain qui lui-même a
fait appel à hasard donc à l'association
africaine des eau et aquarium en disant
bah écoutez on a un problème faites
quelque chose venez aider et donc bah
l'association a répondu présente
évidemment et les eos et aquarium
membres de l'association en question ont
récupéré chacun euh bah 200 poussins par
là 500 de ce côté une centaine par
là-bas en fonction de leur capacité
d'accueil évidemment et grâce à leur
staff qui a qui a pas pas mal bossé bah
ils ont pu les élever eux-même donc ça
ici c'était donc euh ushaka je crois
marine World ouais c'est écrit là voilà
et donc qui avait mis en place alors eux
normalement c'est un aquarium mais ils
ont quand même quelques oiseaux d'au
genre des manchau du cap et ce genre de
choses et du coup ils avaient mis en
place
certains certains anciens anciens
bassins qui ne servait plus à ce
moment-là pour servir de de nurcerie de
pouponnière pour les les petits flamand
c'était c'était assez marrant mais bon
heureusement que ils avaient un petit
peu de place pour le faire sinon ça
aurait été compliqué et puis il y a
plein d'autres zo cour répondu présent
euh en l'occurrence ici par exemple
c'était à Prétoria en bref il y a plein
d'endroits où on on les verra ensemble
donc voilà donc ça c'est le début de
l'histoire on est en janvier 2019 fin
janvier 2019 moi j'étais sur
Johannesbourg des petits flamands
arrivent par avion depuis Kimberly euh
pour être distribué dans les eaux du
coin qui participe à l'opération en
l'occurrence ici le zoau de Prétoria où
j'ai participé moi-même à l'élevage de
ces coussins il y a eu quoi il y a eu le
zoone Midrand et puis il y en a eu deux
trois autres sur Johannesbourg qui ont
aidé à faire ça et puis après ça s'est
réparti aussi dans d'autres eau sur le
pays donc sur la côte du côté de Durban
du côté de porte ellisabeth du côté de
Cape Town enfin bref un peu partout ça a
été vraiment une grosse opération est-ce
qu'il y a des questions jusque là avant
qu'on continue c'est le Flaman qui
fabrique le monticule avec ses pattes
oui c'est le flamant qui fabrique le
monticule avec ses pattes et son bec
exactement et B il faut bien qu'ils se
débrouille parce que de toute façon ils
ont pas de pelle comment ça se fait
qu'il a trois œu dans le lit sur la
photo s'il y a flamon pour un neuf les
familles flamand partagent les mêmes nid
ce sont juste en moyenne un mais ça
peutre dé triplés alors c'est
généralement un mais effectivement des
fois peut y avoir plusieurs œufs ça peut
aussi être un un nid qui est en zo et
dans ces cas-là ça dépend comment les
les les gens en zo ont décidé de gérer
la chose des fois on rajoute un ou deux
des fois il y a un œuf qu'on a rajouté
dans le li et qui en fait un faux œuf
pour encourager la ponte des œufs
suivants enff il y a plein de
possibilités donc c'est possible qu'on
ait aussi des œufs qui devraient pas
être là parce que c'est des œufs qui
sont dans un eau par exemple je sais pas
j'ai pas regardé la légende de la fute
alors c'est un œuf par an mais l'année
prochaine les flamangs vont prendre
d'autres œufs ça prend bien quand même
plusieurs œufs ah bah oui évidemment
c'est un œuf par an ça sachant qu'il
peut y avoir d'autres pontes derrière
parce que des fois si la nourriture est
suffisante si les conditions climatiques
sont suffisantes et ben du coup les
flamants peuvent pondre d'autres ufs
derrière peuvent faire une deuxième
ponte voir même une troisième ponte
certaines fois c'est un peu compliqué et
puis mais c'est effectivement
normalement un une reproduction par an
avec un ou deux œufs maximum les bébés
flamand ça mange pas tout seul des
cenobctérias dans l'eau sans se noyer
quand même donner des Libron des BES de
soupe on va en parler tout de suite on
va voir comment ça marche tout ça mais
ouais des bols de soupe et des bibronsou
effectivement euh on était pas loin bien
vu donc effectivement ça mange pas tout
seul les bébés flamands donc il a fallu
qu'on s'en occupe euh ça c'était juste
on a avant qu'on s'occupe de ça on a
reçu pas mal d'aide international aussi
donc c'était c'était vraiment sympa faut
savoir que les associations de zoos en
l'occurrence l'association des EOS
africains fait partie de l'Association
mondiale des eos et aquarium et grâce à
ça ils ont pu demander de l'aide pour
pour les les Flamands via la société
internationale qui donc a demandé de
l'aide à d'autres zoau ici le zoau D3
par exemple qui disait que l'un de leurs
vétérinaires était justement en Afrique
du Sud et elle est partie aider à ce
moment-là et c'est pas que le zoo D3 on
a eu plein de d'aide de zoo
nord-américain notamment français aussi
bref il y a eu de l'aide un peu partout
et c'était c'était très très sympa de
voir la communauté se mobilisé comme ça
j'avais donc deux trois images à vous
montrer des images qui sont euh
bah comment ça s'est passé à l'époque
c'est des des photos que j'ai prises moi
quand euh quand j'ai aidé au projet sur
place et donc ça par exemple c'est du
bébé flamand alors c'est marrant parce
que les bébés flamands ils ressemblent
pas du tout aux adultes si enfin pas du
tout un petit peu quand même mais en
gros quand vous voyez ça vous avez pas
l'impression que c'est vraiment un
flamant rose rien que le bec si vous
regardez le bec en fait il est même pas
recourbé il est il est tout droit le
petit bec quand il naissent alors ça
c'est des des petits qui ont 3 jours
peut-être quatre maison
euh ils ont un bec qui est tout droit en
fait ils ont pas du tout le bec des
parents et c'est seulement Aiss que
petit à petit ça se développe pareil
pour les pâtes finalement ils ont pas
des pâtes si grandes que ça comparit à
leur corps ils sont tu as vraiment
l'impression d'être d'avoir des trucs
vraiment tout petits et c'est vraiment
des petites boules de Fleuf c'est trop
mignon donc là ici c'est c'est un truc
typique qu'on avait pour pour la nuit
pour les les petits flamament donc vous
avez ici une lampe chauffante qu'on voit
pas au-dessus qui est posée là là
c'était les gamelles de nourriture et
d'eau pour les encourager à manger par
eux-même même s'il mangeent pas vraiment
par eu même à cette périod là ils sont
un peu petits euh vous avez évidemment
de l'astrourf en bas pour aider à ce
qu'il ne n'écarte pas trop les pattes et
qui reste quand même à peu près à peu
près stable des petites couvertures à
droite et à gauche pour qu'il se fasse
pas mal et puis un plumeau parce que le
plumeau c'est super important euh pour
les bébés oiseaux comme ça qui
normalement all nu tombé sont censés se
réfugier sous la maman ou le papa et
normalement ils viennent sous les plumes
en fait et ben là du coup le plumeau ça
sert de de rôle de de de maman parce que
comme ça la nuit pour se réfugier il se
mettent en dessous du du plumeau et ça
fait ça fait comme si il y avait maman
voilà c'est très important et sinon on
leur donnait aussi des des nounours
c'était marrant il se mettait à côté des
penuches aussi c'est un peu triste aussi
hélas voilà donc ça ça vous montre un
truc un peu un petit typique commencer
un
petit un enclot typique de flamand
sachant qu'évidemment on a fait on a
fait avec ce qu'on a pu parce que quand
vous avez un truc comme ça qui vous
arrive sur la sur la tronche vous
imaginez bien là dans le zoau où on
était on avait 200 petits flamands ça
c'est juste un des encloss c'est c'est
un des trucs mais on avait une salle
complète une grande salle et et dans la
grande salle vous en avez 200 qu'il faut
nourrir toutes les 2 heures de 6 à 8h du
soir de 6h du matin à 8h du soir euh
faut préparer la nourriture évidemment
parce que tu peux pas la préparer à
l'avance parce que sinon après c'est
plus assez frais il y a plus assez de
vitamines en ça marche pas euh faut tout
nettoyer régulièrement parce que là
l'enclos par exemple il a l'air il a
l'air déjà vachement sale he et je peux
vous assurer que ça c'est un enclot qui
avait été changé je sais pas 1 heure
avant 2h avant peut-être ça avait été
nettoyé mais
c'est c'est c'est du boulot mais tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps et et
j'ai fait pas mal de j'ai passé pas mal
de de soirées complètes de nuit euh sur
place juste pour aider à à faire tout ça
voilà donc ça par exemple c'est un bébé
flamand vous voyez bien le bec qui est
bien
droit ici hop comparé aux adultes alors
là c'était le nourrissage j'allais
j'allais faire le nourrissage on nourrit
à la seringue c'est c'est pas toujours
simple parce que ils sont ils sont assez
ils sont motivés vous pouvez le voir ils
sont très motivés et du coup ils
essaient de de de de choper tout ce
qu'ils peuvent pour prendre à manger par
c'est normal hein c'est c'est des c'est
l'instinct de survie mais mais c'est pas
facile de les faire tenir tranquille
pour arriver à insérer la pipette dans
la bouche et le tube et puis le mettre
au bon endroit pour qu'il pour qu'il
s'étouffe pas viser dans le bon trou
parce que vous avez deux trous au fond
de la gorge vous avez l'eusophage qui
effectivement est l'endroit où vous êtes
censé mettre le tube et puis vous avez
la trachée qui et les poumons en
l'occurrence c'est sa qui rien pour les
oiseaux où vous ne voulez pas mettre le
tube en question et et ça c'est un petit
peu un petit peu dangereux donc faut
bien faire gaffe voilà euh donc ça c'est
c'est juste pour vous montrer un petit
peu comment ça se passait bon ça c'était
c'est c'est les tout petits du
coup 3 qu jours c'est vraiment les les
tout bébés bébés alors ensuite qu'est-ce
qui se passe bah ça grandit et ça
grandit vite un oiseau heureusement
d'ailleurs parce que à ce rythme là on
avait un peu du mal à suivre non et ça
c'est les petits flamands à un peu moins
d'un mois et vous commencez à voir que
le bec il commence déjà à se recourber
ici
la couleur du plumage est pas du tout la
même on est passé sur un duvet qui est
plus blanc il est plus dans les
grisâtres vous avez les pâtes bien noir
cette fois-ci elles sont plus du tout
roses comme elles l'était au début parce
que si vous regardez les
premières a Paris là tant pis en gros si
vous regardez les premières photos ils
ont des papates toutes roses c'est très
marrant hop donc ça grandit et on
commence à voir apparaître les premières
plumes alors tout ça évidemment je vous
le fais en accéléré là mais faut faut
bien imaginer que c'est c'est un peu
c'est c'est quelques nuits sans sommeil
i sur le sur le moment voilà une petite
vidéo des
bestioles voilà essayer de manger mon
portable
absolument donc là ils étaient dehors on
essaie de de les garder en extérieur au
maximum pour qu'il s'habitue aussi parce
que faut pas les garder en intérieur
tout le temps c'est c'est plus
intéressant pour eux d'être en extérieur
voilà à table et donc là le le bec est
encore changer un petit peu il se ça
fait vraiment c espèce de C de de de de
courbe c'est c'est assez drôle et puis
ils sont tout doux ils sont ils sont ils
sont tout fleufu là ils sont ils sont
très mignons voilà voilà voilà alors le
bec du flamand c'est quelque chose
d'assez intéressant parce qu'en fait
vous avez ici des sortes de toutes
petites denticues je sais pas si on voit
bien sur la
photo là on voit peut-être un peu mieux
on voit des des toutes petites
denticules sur le côté et c'est ça qui
va leur servir à filtrer donc en fait
quand il filtre alors je vous ai mis une
une vidéo après normalement on la verra
il retournent la tête et ils utilisent
le bec comme ça à l'horizontale à
l'envers pour filtrer l'eau et pour
récupérer bah des petits trucs qui
peuvent qui peuvent choper à l'intérieur
que ce soit des canobactéries des
micro-organismes autres ou n'importe et
ça ça c'est super c'est super amusant
vraiment de les voir la tête à l'envers
comme ça pour essayer de filtrer c'est
très très
marrant voilà voilà hop ça grandit
encore un peu on est de semaines après
les petites plumes que vous aviez
commencé à avoir là à l'état de vraiment
encore à l'intérieur de leur de leur sac
bah là ça y est ça commence à sortir on
est vraiment sur sur des plumes de vol
qui commencent à apparaître en fait
c'est pas encore le plumage complet
parce que vous allez voir qu'il y a
encore beaucoup de duvet partout mais on
commence à voir le plumage qui va être
leur premier plumage leur plumage de
juvénil qui commence à apparaître ici ce
sont ces plumes blanches ici voilà qui
sont les les premières plume vraiment à
pousser du du plumage pas adulte mais
juvénil plus plus en quelque
sorte donc voilà ici vous les voyez un
peu plus un peu plus poussé donc ça
c'est les plumes bien noires qu'on
voyait au début là commen à ressortir ça
c'est les les plumes de vol les
primaires donc là à ce stade là il
volent pas encore mais il commence déjà
à planer un petit peu et là il fait ses
exercices là lui pour essayer de de
muscler ses ailes c'est un peu ce qu'on
lui demande hop et ensuite on a arrive à
la seconde partie qui va être la partie
où on va essayer de relâcher tout ce
beonde parce que c'est bien beau d'avoir
3000 petits en captivité mais ce qu'on
veut c'est pas les garder en captivité
ce qu'on veut c'est les lâcher
idéalement et évidemment pour ça il va
falloir leur mettre des petites bagues
alors des petites bagues qui
ressemblent à ça ça c'est une petite
bague qu'on va mettre un oiseau donc en
fait c'est un truc comme ça ça s'ouvre
ici sur le dessus voilà donc vous les
faites chauffer un petit peu mettez dans
l'eau chaude pas chauffer à blanc
évidemment mais vous les mettez dans
l'eau chaude ça se détend un peu ça
s'ouvre et vous pouvez la mettre sur la
pâte et après ça se referme une fois que
vous le le repliez et donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui va permettre aux
ornitologues de les voir de loin à la
jumelle et comme c'est il y a un très
bon contraste làdessus de du noir sur du
jaune comme ça de loin ça se voit bien
puis en plus le jaune réfléchit un peu
la lumière donc c'est facile à voir donc
ça va vous permettre d'identifier les
individus les uns à côté des autres même
quand ils sont sont au loin sur le lac
donc ça c'est bien pratique voilà des
questions jusque là avant qu'on passe à
la suite si bactéries est-ce que c'est
pas dangereux je suis pas biologiste
alors nous on manipule pas les
canobactéries nous ce qu'on leur a donné
à manger c'est d'autres trucs d' on peut
en parler vite fait ce qu'on leur donne
à manger en fait c'est une sorte de
nourriture complet pour flamand en
captivité c'est des la nourriture du
début quand ils sont tout petits on
essaie de leur donner un truc qui va
ressembler au lait de flamand alors si
vous connaissez un petit peu les les
Flamands vous savez que comme les
pigeons ils produisent ce qu'on appelle
du lait du lait de Jabo et c'est pas
vraiment du lait comme un mammifère il y
a pas de glande Mamère ou quoi que ce
soit mais en gros c'est un lait qu'ils
vont produire grâce au contenu de ce
qu'ils ont dans leur osophage dans leur
jabau d'où le nom lesit Jabo et qui vont
régurgiter via le bec pour donner à leur
petits ça donne pour les Flamands ça
donne un liquide qui est assez rougeâtre
généralement et ça va ça va les nourrir
c'est c'est très très très calorique et
du coup ça va permettre petits flamands
de bien grandir alors nous pour recréer
le lait de Jabo pour les petits flamands
on a utilisé il y avait une recette je
donne la recette comme ça si vous si
vous avez des flamants à la maison on
sait jamais euh du coup vous avez des
œufs durs euh seulement le jaune par
contre pas le reste euh vous mixez avec
des crevettes vous mixez alors il y
avait deux trois compléments alimentaire
qu'on rajoute avec et vous mixez avec de
la bléine pour bébé mais seulement la BL
à base de farine de riz vous pouvez pas
utiliser celle à base de farine de blé
ça marche pas enfin c'est pas
suffisamment bien pour les Flamands ils
ont du mal à digérer donc voilà ça c'est
la recette pour les petits flamands pour
faire du lait Jabo si vous en avez à la
maison n'hésitez pas par contre pas pour
les bébés c'est pas forcément une bonne
idée mais juste pour vous donner une
idée en fait vous imaginez bien qu'une
recette avec du jaune d'œuf et des
crevettes ça finit par coûter cher par
contre et quand vous devez en faire des
baquets pour la journée c'est pas mal je
peux vous assurer c'est pas top alors
j'ai pas goûté moi-même peut-être qu'il
aurait fallu que je goûte mais mais
ouais c'est euh ça a bien marché ils ont
bien grandit il y a pas de souci mais
par contre ça sent pas très bon après
quand ça quand ça reste en dehors du
frigo pendant un petit moment alors
comment ça pousse un bec comme un ongle
chez nous c'est une sorte de la kératine
morte donc je veux dire que c'est le
bout du bec adulte qui pousse d'abord
puis quand ils sont àos ça tourne ou
bien c'est vivant un bec alors
euh dans le bec vous avez deux trucs
vous avez pour faire simple vous avez à
la fois
l'os qui va être en l'occurrence le
prémaxillaire sur l'avant du bec et le
maxillaire un petit peu plus vers
l'arrière que vous connaissez
certainement et vous avez par-dessus
l'os une enveloppe cornée qui est
effectivement de la kératine qui va
pousser aussi régulièrement cette
kératine qui va en fait être usé petit à
petit par l'utilisation du bec donc ça
c'est les deux parties du bec les plus
importantes en quelque sor vous avez la
langue à l'intérieur aussi mais enfin ça
c'est pas vraiment le plus important
pour la structure du bec euh en gros
c'est comme ça donc en fait quand le bec
pousse chez les petits oiseau il se
développe déjà c'est c'est l'os qui va
se développer et l'enveloppe cornée qui
se développe en plus par-dessus donc les
deux pouces en même temps ce qui va vous
donner en la forme qui va se recourber
un petit peu c'est à la fois euh
d'ailleurs si vous regardez un crâne de
flamand vous verrez c'est le
prémaxillaire qui va se recourber aussi
et avec euh la l'enveloppe cornée
par-dessus qui va pousser en même temps
tout simplement pour poursuivre donc si
vous regardez un crâne de flamand
peut-être essayer d'en trouver un voilà
donc en fait vous avez ici le bec qui
est donc constitué du prémaxillaire
principalement vous avez le maxillaire
qui va s'arrêter là normalement et puis
la mandibule pareil qui va aussi être
osseuse et par-dessus laquelle va se
placer l'enveloppe cornée enveloppe
cornée sur laquelle vous allez avoir les
petites dents que je vous ai montré tout
à l'heure les petites denticules en fait
font partie de l'enveloppe cornée c'est
pas des dents à part entière hein c'est
vraiment la kératine qui forme des
petits plie sur les côtés pour aider à
la filtration mais très bonne question
cela dit au sol l'astrotur que vous avez
montré c'est une espèce de faux gazon en
plastique j'imagine c'est non non c'est
complètement une espèce de faux glazon
en plastique en fait le but de
l'astroturf on aurait pu mettre il y a
aussi d'autres trucs qui fonctionnent en
silicone et des des sortes de tapis en
silicone qu'on utilise un peu plus tard
aussi généralement quand vous élevez un
petit oiseau vous allez mettre ça au
fond parce que d'une c'est simple à
nettoyer pou passer à la machine vous
pouvez passer au carcher ça résiste et
de deux ça évite qu'en fait les pattes
de l'oiseau elle ne fasse ça elle ne
s'écarte et du
coup si vous avez un fond de de de nid
comment dire qui qui n'est pas
suffisamment texturé les pâtes elles
vont glisser sur le côté et comme le
petit oiseau bah c'est quelque chose qui
est encore c'est un bébé c'est encore
tout méable c'est encore du cartilage de
partout ça ça a pas fini de pousser ben
si jamais les pâtes elles restent comme
ça pendant trop longtemps ben il va
garder cette conformation à l'état
adulte et on veut pas ça quand le petit
oiseau il grandit donc en fait tu
essayes de faire un sol de nid de nid
artificiel hein j'entends qui soit aussi
texturé que possible pour que les pâtes
restent bien sous le corps et que du
coup on nit pas de souci c'est
particulièrement un souci avec les
échassiers comme les bah comme les les
Flamands parce que du coup les grandes
pâtes euh ça ça ça peut facilement
sarquer quand c'est petit et quand c'est
tout malléable donc faut faire super
gaffe on fait aussi super gaffe quand on
élève les petits perroquet par exemple
en captivité ou bien d'autres ces
d'oiseau c'est toujours super important
alors comment fait pour pas au fait
qu'il y a pas de parents pour les
éduquer c'est c'est compliqué alors
l'avantage des Flamands c'est que c'est
des espèces qui sont qui sont en groupe
donc à partir du moment où vous les
élevez en groupe de toute façon ils vont
réussir à à comprendre que leur voisin
qui a un flamant ça fait aussi partie du
même groupe donc ils vont se reconnaître
en tant que flamand normalement et puis
euh et puis après c'est c'est un oiseau
aussi qui a pas non plus des il y a
beaucoup d'instincts mais il y a pas
énormément de trucs qui sont appris en
fait tous les tous les comport comport
que je vais vous montrer après c'est des
comportements qu'ils ont appris
naturellement qui sont instinctifs et
qu'on on a pas eu besoin de leur montrer
genre comment manger par exemple avec la
tête à l'envers comme ça c'est
complètement instinctif on a pas eu
besoin de leur montrer ils savent faire
ça tout seul donc normalement pour la
base des comportements ils savent le
faire tout seul après là où ça va être
un peu plus compliqué ça va être pour
les relations sociales entre flamand
mais je vais vous en montrer deux trois
et vous allez voir qu'en fait il se
débrouille tout seul aussi surtout que
si vous les AZ en groupe génalement ça
finit par il y en a un qui finit par par
dominer plus ou moins enfin bref il y a
il y a des relations déjà qui se passe
entre les petits flamands et
généralement ils ont pas besoin de plus
voilà c'est une espèce qui est quand
même assez simple de ce point de vue là
donc ça va on n pas eu trop de problème
pour d'autres espèces plus plus
difficiles on aurait eu certainement
plus de problèmesup des B faion par les
humains ok mais je suis toujours surpris
que ça dérange pas les animaux des bag
bien visibles quand on sait pourtant que
F attention à leur look avec des parades
sexuel par exemple bah après c'est comme
tout est-ce que la parade sexuelle c'est
important pour l'animal en question de
bien voir les pattes et de rien avoir
sur les pattes si c'est le cas bah du
coup effectivement la bague va être un
problème mais si lappade sexuelle ne
porte pas forcément sur la la pâte et sa
couleur ou sa texture ou n'importe ben
dans ces cas-là avoir une bague c'est
pas trop un problème et en l'occurrence
pour les Flamands la parade sexuelle
c'est pas trop les pattes qui regardent
normalement chez les oiseaux c'est plus
le plumage qui est qui est important
pour l'pparade sexuel pas vraiment les
pattes donc normalement ça passe plutôt
bien
normalement mais c'est vrai que ça c'est
une c'est une bonne question
effectivement c'est une bonne question
on va arriver à un moment où il va
falloir les relâcher parce que là vous
avez vu ils ont bien grandi ils sont
devenir alors pas encore tout à fait
suffisamment grand mais il va falloir
quand même les ramener à Kimberly pour
les relâcher à l'endroit où ils sont
censés être en l'occurrence sur le lac
qui pendant ce tempslà a finalement été
reempli grâce à la fois au conditions
climatique parce que il y a eu de l'eau
il a eu il y avait eu une grose
sécheresse aussi précédemment ce qui
fait que ça avait pas arrangé les choses
mais là tout d'un coup il y a eu une
période de pluie de grossse pluies qui
continue d'ailleurs et qui du coup a
permis de renflouer un petit peu le lac
et puis la ville a fini par discuter
avec les entreprises qui normalement
étaient censé relâcher de l'eau dans le
lac ce qui fait que bah du coup le lac a
retrouvé un niveau bon pas pas énorme
non plus mais suffisant pour que les
Flamands puissent à nouveau survivre sur
le lac
donc ça c'est ce qu'on va voir tout de
suite et et ce qu'ils vont faire
justement ce qui va se passer maintenant
c'est qu'il va falloir ramener tous ces
flamands à côté du lac alors comment
est-ce que ça se passe bah ici vous
voyez des caisses qui ont été faites
spécialement pour les Flamands en
question pour les envoyer à Kimberly qui
sont partis donc par avion
euh voilà ce pour le coup c'était des
caisses en carton assez basiques mais
renforcé quand même pour éviter qu'il y
ait des problèmes mais bon il volait pas
pendant très longtemps donc c'était
c'était suffisant et puis une fois sur
place il y a une structure qui a été
construite que je retrouve voilà une
structure qui a énorme suffisamment
grande en tout cas pour accueillir tous
les petits flamands qui a été constru
qui est euh ce grand parc ici couvert
qui est en fait
une un centre de réhabilitation pour les
Flamands et surtout de préparation au
futurs lâchés qu'on va pouvoir faire
parce que il va falloir évidemment
relâcher ses flamands sur le lac donc
c'est constitué ici d'une très grande
volière avec au fond là-bas une sorte de
de mini lac euh avec des pompes avec
plein de trucs
voilà ici hop la vue du mini LAAC sur
lequel on avait installé bah de quoi euh
de quoi les nourrir pour les encourager
notamment à trouver leur nourriture dans
l'eau parce que ça c'est un des
problèmes qu'on a rencontré aussi
sachant que depuis tout petit on les
avait gardé plus ou moins sur la terre
ferme on avait pas accès c'est un lac
euh sur laquelle
les sur laquel les les les posé pour
qu'il comprennent que c'est là qu'il
faut aller manger donc ce il a fallu
faire aussi dans cet endroit-là c'est
arriver à leur montrer que sur le lac
c'est là où on a la nourriture donc là
ici on était passé une sorte
de pas des croquettes mais enfin ça
ressemblait pas mal c'est des c'est
pareil c'est de la nourriture pour
flamand que vous mettez dans dans de
l'eau en fait c'est des petites
croquettes qui qui flottent et que les
Flamands récupèrent avec leur bec en fil
TR en l'eau aussi donc ça c'était un
autre type de nourriture adapté à
eux une autre vue du lac en question
ouais je plus c'est un mini lac hein
juste pour vous dire que il faisait
froid parce que là on arrive en alors on
arrive en avril mai ça c'est plus plus
mai en en mai en Afrique du Sud c'est
l'inverse c'est l'hiver en fait en mai
c'est en en janvier c'est l'été en
décembre janvier c'est l'été et en mai
c'est l'hiver donc ça c'était le matin
quand j' arrivais pour m'occuper des
Flamands ça c'était ce que je trouvais
c'estàd que l'eau elle gèle la nuit il
fait un peu froid alors quand vous vous
occupez de petit comme ça que vous êtes
tout le temps dehors et qui et qui
caille je peux vous assurer que que vos
mains elles en prennent un coup surtout
quand il faut jouer avec de l'eau de
l'eau qui est mais ultra
glacée ça fait un peu froid alors
euh un problème qu'on avait rencontré à
l'époque et c'est la raison pour
laquelle vous me voyez ici euh avec ce
flamand dans l'eau on fait pas n'importe
quoi là en fait on fait un nettoyage de
Flamands les petits flamands à l'époque
euh au tout début on les avait nourris
avec donc la mixture dont je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure avec de l'œuf et de
la crevette et euh de la purée pour bébé
mais après ils ont évolué ils sont
passés sur une nourriture de flamand un
peu plus adulte une fois qu'ils ont
commencé à manger tout seul ce qui
s'appelle du Flamingo rage bon en gros
ce Flamingo red c'est une sorte
de de bouillie rougeâtre qui qui
contient notamment les
les ce qui est important pour pour la
coloration du du flamon mais le problème
c'est que ces
pigments ces pigments là ils ont aussi
tendance à coller un petit peu aux
plumes surtout quand le flamand a décidé
qu'il prendrait son bain dans le
dans la bouillie en question ce qui
arrivait plus d'une fois avec beaucoup
de Flamands et du coup à la fin on é
retrouvé avec des Flamands qui qui
finalement n'étaient plus gris comme ils
étaient censé l'être et qui étaient
devenus des vrais flamants roses et et
le problème de C ces pigments et de
cette bouillie qui est finalement très
riche et qui contient pas mal de graisse
aussi c'est que bah ça colle bien aux
plumes c'est très gras et que même si
après le flamand commence à partir se
laver dans l'eau comme on leur avait
passé un
grand pas un lac mais une grande zone
d'eau bien bien claire quand même donc
ils allaient se se baigner dedans ils
étaient bien contents mais mais le le
pigment rouge ne partait pas de leurs
plumes et notamment c'est cette c'est
c'est cette substance un petit peu
collante qu'ils avaient en plus du
pigment qui restait sur les PL et ben ça
les empêchait d'être complètement
waterproof le problème pour un un oiseau
bah flamand ou n'importe quel autre
oiseau d'au d'ailleurs c'est que
normalement pour qu'il reste bien au
chaud ils ont une une couche de plume
extérieur qu'on appelle des plumes de
couverture les plumes de couverture qui
sont censé être là en protection contre
les éléments à l'extérieur et notamment
contre l'eau surtout si vous avez des
oiseaux d'eau qui se baignent
régulièrement et qui va protéger le
duvet qui est en dessous qui est bien
chaud et qui est censé donc maintenir
votre oiseau au chaud surtout quand il
fait froid comme comme c'était le cas
pendant ce moislà où on se cailler
oui sauf que avec cette cette couche de
flamingoed par-dessus bah du coup ça ça
ne protégeit plus grand-chose et les
plumes étaient un peu toutes collé et
c'était pas top et donc on pouvait pas
lâcher les les flamants comme ça
évidemment donc bah ce qu'on a fait
c'est que on a pris ce qui étaient
effectivement les plus rouges et les
plus embêtés et qui avaient pris
l'habitude de se baigner dans dans ses
bacs avec leur repas dedans et puis ben
on les a lavés alors avec un savon
adapté évidemment mais voilà ils sont
passés au lavage voilà et du coup après
on leur a laissé quelques jours
évidemment pour qu'il s'en remettent et
pour que de nouveau lisser leur plumage
utiliser la petite glande eururopyienne
donc la glande qu'ils ont à l'arrière
sur leur croupion pour
pouvoir lisser leurs plumes correctement
et les rendre à nouveau imperméables et
après ça on a pu les relâcher bon il y a
eu deux trois autres opérations comme là
ici il y a toujours quelques oiseaux qui
sont pas forcément en forme donc là on
leur donne par exemple un petit antibiot
à celui-là qui qui était un peu malade
voilà parce que voilà et ça c'est ce
qu'on obtient derrière c'estd que ça
c'est la couleur normale d'un jeune
flamand de de l'espèce du flamant
nain ça c'est un flamant nain de
première année donc vous voyez il y a
pas du tout de rouge en fait sur les
plume c'est c'est la coloration normale
alors il y en a qui sont un petit peu
plus rosé que ça un petit peu plus brun
aussi ça dépend de l'individu mais mais
ça normalement le gris est noir c'est
c'est c'est très dark mais c'est c'est
censé être la coloration normale du
flamand et ça c'est pas du tout ce qu'on
avait parce que si on regarde alors ça
ça çaen a un autre par exemple un peu
plus brun mais vous voyez bien il y a
pas de de rose sur les plumes et le
problème c'est que si on
regarde que je retrouve d'autres voilà
si on regarde les ntres là vous voyez
qu'il y a pas mal de Ros encore alors
ils ont commencé à muer ici parce que
ils commencent à prendre leur deuxième
plumage de juvénile derrière parce que
ils ont ils ont plusieurs
m pour eux donc là par exemple ici vous
vous voyez il y a des plumes roses qui
ont commencé à se barrer qui ont été
remplacé par des plumes grises c'est le
le deuxième plumage de juvénil que cette
fois-ci ils vont garder jusqu'à l'année
suivante mais mais en attendant ces
plumesl qui sont roses ne sont pas du
tout waterprouf et du coup l'oiseau
quand il se baigne ben il est trempé
jusqu'au duvet en dessous et et il peut
tout à fait finir en hypothermie donc ça
c'est typiquement ce qu'on ne veut pas
et c'est pour ça qu'on avait commencé à
laver des oiseaux avant de de pouvoir
les relâcher sinon c'est c'était juste
pas possible donc voilà donc ça c'est ça
s'est passé à Kimberly dans l'endroit où
on a commencé à ramener tous les
Flamands qui avaient été envoyés dans
tout le pays on les a tous ramené à
Kimberly dans cet endroit-là dans ce
dans ce petit centre qui a été construit
rapidement pour le relâcher de ces
oiseaux là ensuite pourquoi la polière
fermée vu que le but c'est qu'il s'en
aille pour pas être embêté par les
vautau alors c'est pas trop les votours
le problème le problème c'est tous les
prédateurs qu'on avait dans le coin
alors on a à la fois des bangostes qui
sont tout à fait cap capable de choper
un bébé flamand et de le manger on a à
la fois des wild dogs donc les les
licaons par exemple on va avoir aussi
tous les chiens et les chatirants qui
sont tout à fait capables de les manger
aussi et puis ben on a tout ce qui est
léopard Cerval Caracal sans compter et
ça c'est encore un truc dont on
discutera après les gens qui habitent à
côté qui font partie des township donc
des des endroits qui sont des bidons
ville en français je crois euh et qui
dans ces t chips ils sont ils sont
toujours à la recherche de nourriture et
notamment de protéines et c'est
tellement simple d'aller récupérer un
Flamand un jeune flamand comme ça de le
choper et puis d'en faire un barbecue
derrière donc bah on était obligé de de
protéger un peu tout le monde et de de
s'assurer queil y a rien qui vienne
voler à l'intérieur de l'enclos aussi
voir sauter à l'intérieur de l'enclos
pour aller choper des flamants qu'on a
qu'on qu'on avait quand même vachement
travaillé à à remettre en état et et à
amener à ce point-là si tu veux quand
quand tu travailles autant pour arriver
à amener tous ces ces petits flamaments
d' d'un état du tout petit truc de 3
jours jusqu'à 3 mois comme comme ils ont
là jusqu'au point où tu peux les
relâcher en fait c'est tellement
d'effort que tu as investi dans ces
animaux là tellement de temps d'argent
de de de d'émotion aussi souvent que que
tu as pas envie qu'il soit chopé par le
premier truc qui passe donc tu essaes de
de les protéger au maximum jusqu'au
moment où tu dois effectivement les
relâcher donc c'était ça aussi le
principe sans compter qu'il y a aussi
des lois et qu'il faut faire avec ces
lois c'est-à-dire que tu peux pas juste
relâcher une btile comme ça notamment
dans une opération de cette envergure on
était mandaté par le gouvernement
sud-africain en l'occurrence et le
gouvernement sud-africain aidé de ces
vétérinaires d'État avait mis en place
tout un protocole auquel donc les les e
avaient adhéré et avaiit aidé à par au
protocole aussi évidemment
euh ils avaient mis en place tout un
protocole pour le relâcher de ces
oiseaux pour que ça se fasse dans les
meilleures conditions possibles et donc
on pouvait pas juste faire ça comme ça
en disant allez allez-y les petits soyez
librees non ça marche pas comme
ça ça
c'étaitant qu'on nettoyait les trucs
voilà ça vous donne une idée alors on
avait des volontaires qui étaient là sur
place qui étaient gentiment venus aider
aussi c'est c'est alors là il y en a un
qui tient l'oiseau pendant qu'il y a
l'autre qui essaie de de nettoyer un peu
et donc on terminait avec des oiseaux
qui finalement étaient plus ou moins
prêts à être relâchés comme celui-là
avec joli plumage tout propre on
attendait donc quelques jours que ça se
refasse correctement et puis bah il
pouvait il pouvait
repartir évidemment avant de les
relâcher ils ont tous leur petite bagu
ici et ici sur certains on avait mis un
petit émetteur qui est donc une sorte de
de d'émetteur GPS avec un mini panneau
solaire que vous voyez ici sur le dos
voilà voilà mais j'ai trop mini et et ça
ça a permis de les suivre pendant un
certain temps pour voir un petit peu où
il migrer parce que c'est aussi
important lorsque vous faites un
programme de conservation d'avoir de la
recherche qui est associé au programme
de conservation parce que
euh vous pouvez pas juste faire une
action comme ça d'aussi grande ampleur
et ne rien en tirer derrière c'est
important non seulement pour le
flamandin mais aussi pour d'Ar espèces
de flamand d'arriver à comprendre
comment pourquoi et qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire nous pour aider et donc ça c'est
le but de ces capteurs ici de pouvoir
essayer de mieux comprendre en
l'occurrence la répartition des Flamands
et de savoir comment et pourquoi ils
volaient à droite à gauche pourquoi ils
étaient venus à Kimberly pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils étaient reparti de Kimberly s'ils
étaient reparti de Kimberly où est-ce
qu'ils étaient partis est-ce que ces
jeunesl si jamais il les retrouvaient
pas ils seraient quand même capable de
retrouver leur chemin à droite et à
gauche est-ce qu'il reviendrai plus tard
à Kimberly enfin il y a plein de
questions auxquelles on avait envie
d'avoir des réponse et qui ont été
effectivement donné grâce à ces petits
capteurs GPS alors on en a équipé je
crois une vingtaine d'oiseaux avec ça et
certains ont fonctionné encore pendant
un an après ce qui était ce qui était
pas mal du tout au final et donc on
arrive au dernier point qui est
évidemment le lâcher de petits flamands
alors là il y en a qu'une partie parce
qu'en fait on les relâchait pas tous en
même temps on les relâcha groupe par
groupe donc c'est-à-dire que avant de
faire un lâcher d'oiseau tu vas checker
dans ta population captive et OK
lesquels sont prêts à être lâchés alors
lesquels sont à peu près ok lesquels ont
un poids suffisant sont en bonne
condition physique donc tu tu tâes au
niveau du du brécher voir sils ont
suffisamment de gras pour survivre
pendant un moment euh lesquels sont
capables sont suffisamment grands aussi
parce que tu relâches pas les plus
petits il y en avait qui étaient un peu
plus jeunes aussi qui avaent éclos après
enfin bref fallait gérer un peu tout ça
et lesquels sont en bonne santé aussi
parce qu' évidemment en captivité tu as
toujours des oiseaux qui chopent un
rhume qui sont malades
qui sont fait mal d'une manière ou d'une
autre parce qu'ils sont pris dans le
grillage ou je ne sais quoi donc faut
faire gaffe et tu relâches pas n'importe
comment et n'importe quoi donc ça
c'était un des lâchés avec les petits
flamands sur le lac voilà et ils sont
partis et donc après ils sont partir
rejoindre la colonie les quelques
flamands qui étaient revenus sur le lac
à cette période là c'est pour ça qu'on
les qu'on les avait lâché à ce allez
allez on s'en va et moi aussi les poules
joue avec des bols de graines on va
partout chedans du coup une solution est
de mettre un grillage sur le bol qui
laisse passer que le bec c'est pas
possible pour les Flamands parce que le
bec est est trop gros si tu mets un
grillage ça passe plus et puis après
avec les petits denticules sur les côtés
en fait ils se prennent dans le grillage
aussi on a eu quelques soucis avec des
becs qui s'étaient pris dans le grillage
à cause des denticules qui du coup se
coince et et bah et quand il tire dessus
comme des dingues pour essayer de
décoincer le bec et ben il s'arrache la
moitié du bec et c'est dommage
euh vous avez mangé du flamand c'est une
question sérieuse sachant qu'un flamant
pas nous non mais je sais qu'il y en a
qui manger mais nous non non pourquoi le
lac en question est-ce qu'il y a pas un
risque de voir le lacasscher à nouveau
celui-ci est dépendant d'industrie il me
semble qu'il n'est pas durable alors
c'est une très très bonne question et
effectivement ça fait partie du côté
politique de la chose maintenant qu'on a
vu un peu l'histoire et comment ça s'est
passé tout ça le premier problème qu'on
a eu c'est que ces oiseaux normalement
n'auraient jamais dû être collectter
dans la nature alors
pourquoi parce que ces animaux en fait
sont pas en danger
d'extinction ils ont bon leur nombre
diminue un petit peu ces derniers temps
c'est vrai mais ils sont pas en danger
d'extinction il faut savoir que dans la
dans la conservation on a déjà pas
beaucoup de crédit à accorder aux
espèces qui sont réellement en voie
d'extinction ou de disparition mais si
en plus on essaie d'utiliser nos
ressources durement gagnées pour
s'occuper d'espèces qui n'en ont pas
besoin bah c'est c'est un peu ridicule
pour pour ces flamands et ce qui s'est
passé après nous a donné
raison les Flamands quand ils sont
revenus à campfedam 2 mois plus tard à
peu près et ben tout de suite comme les
niveaux d'eau étaient remontés et que de
nouveau on avait des canobactéries et
ben tout de suite ils sont remis à
pondre ils ont refait des nid ils ont
repondu ils ont fait une deuxième ponte
deuxième ponte avec à peu près le même
nombre de petits dans la Pte et c'est du
coup en fait on nurait pas eu besoin de
sauver les petits flamands ça aurait pas
été nécessaire à la survie de l'espèce
vu que de toute façon derrière ils
allaient refaire une deuxième alors oui
vous allez me dire on peut pas prévoir
clairement on peut pas prévoir mais
comme c'est pas une espèce qui envoie
d'extinction ou de disparition c'était
pas nécessaire de mettre toutes ces
ressources
dans la survie de ces animaux là pour
vous donner une idée des chiffres de ce
que ça coûte en vrai pour les oiseaux
qui n'ont pas pu être relâchés
c'est-à-dire il y a toujours des oiseaux
dans un groupe qui sont bah soit mal en
point parce que ils sont mal formés
parce que ils ont un problème parce que
ils sont cassé une patte et que ça s'est
mal remis parce que bah ils ont été
malades très longtemps et que ils ont
pas beaucoup grandi du coup tu as
l'impression qu'ils sont MS par rapport
aux autres tous ces oiseaux là qui sont
restés en captivité on en a une petite
centaine mine de rien pour les
garder en captivité pendant un
mois on était à peu près sur 35000
randes par mois juste pour la nourriture
et pour le maintien en captivité pour un
mois alors 35000 Rand une estimation en
euros
ouais on n'est pas loin de 2000 € par
mois pour tous les garder en captivité
alors c'est pas énorme vous allez me
dire mais pour l'Afrique du Sud c'est
beaucoup 35000 r tu les sors pas de ton
chapeau comme ça parce que bon ici les
choses coûtent beaucoup moins cher qu'en
Europe et c'est c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut prendre en compte aussi parce
que ça c'est de l'argent que tu n'as pas
mis
pour d'autres espèces qui en auraient eu
plus besoin alors oui c'est vrai c'est
pas facile de regarder les 3000 et de se
dire ouais non on va rien faire le
problème c'est que quand tu fais de la
conservation et Quand tu es dans ce
milieul il faut que tu fasses des choix
tu as des choix à faire à chaque fois
par exemple on t'amène deux animaux il y
en a un qui est en très mauvaise état tu
sais qu'il passera pas la nuit et il y
en a ou que de toute façon quoi que tu
fasses il pourra pas être relâché plus
tard par contre l'autre qu'on t'amène
lui il a des chances de survie et il va
peut-être pouvoir survivre si tu lui
donnes sa chance mettons par exemple que
tu as ni les finances ni la place ni la
capacité humaine c'est tu as pas
suffisamment de gens pour t'occuper des
deux à la fois tu ne peux t'occuper que
d'un seul bah il va falloir que tu
fasses un choix et le choix ça va être
simple tu vas prendre celui qui a le
plus de chance de survie pour ces petits
flamands c'est pareil si on avait eu le
choix on ne s'en serait pas occupé la
seule raison pour laquelle on s'en est
occupé c'est parce que le gouvernement
africain s'en est mêlé et parce que du
coup ces gens sont partis collecter les
œufs que derrière on s'est dit oui bon
bah ils sont déjà collectés
effectivement on va pas rester sans rien
faire on va les aider un petit peu
clairement ils galèrent faisons quelque
chose mais mais ça aurait été juste les
eos et
aquarium et les divers centres captifs
derrière les œuvs seraient restés dans
la nature faut savoir aussi que ça
aurait certainement servi de repas à
tous les prédateurs du coin parce que
c'est aussi comme ça que les prédateurs
ils peuvent survivre s'il y a des
animaux qui ont besoin bah d'un repasun
prédateur quelconque bah eux du coup ils
pourront survivre grâce à d'autres
btioles qui elles sont en train de
mourir faut savoir aussi que quand vous
retirez une btiole qui est en train de
mourir de la nature bah vous retirez son
pas à un autre
truc donc voilà faut faut faire la part
des choses c'est pas simple et c'est
pour ça qu'on a des spécialistes c'est
pour ça qu'il y a des gens qui sont
capables de dire ça c'est une action qui
est nécessaire ça c'est une action qui
n'est pas nécessaire et en l'occurrence
ça c'était une action qui n'était pas
nécessaire mais qui nous a obligé
derrière à utiliser beaucoup de
ressources qu'on aurait préféré utiliser
autre partère la génération précédente
avait migré donc elle était capable de
survivre qu'elle revienne ou qu'elle
aille ailleurs exactement la génération
précédente avait migré et puis bah de
toute façon ils sont partis sur un autre
lac et puis ils sont revenus plus tard
ils ont refait une deuxième ponte
finalement tout allait bien on aurait
pas eu besoin de s'en mêler voilà et
juste pour vous donner une idée aussi en
tout euh les coûts de gestion de toute
cette opération s'élève à plus de 2
millions de Rand je crois à peu près
pour toute cette opération là jusqu'au
lâcher des petits flamands sans compter
évidemment tout ce qui a été tout ce
qu'on a encore aujourd'hui euh suite à
ces petits flamaments qui sont restés en
captivité parce qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
être lâchés donc tous ces flamaments là
qui sont encore en captivité de nos
jours continuent évidemment à coûter des
sous et ceux-là ne sont pas dans le
calcul donc jusqu'au lâcher au dernier
lâcher de flamand ça a coûté à peu près
2 millions de randes toute cette
opération ce qui est quand même énorme
pour l'Afrique du Sud et ce qu'on aurait
pu mettre autre part c'est c'est
compliqué c'est c'est vraiment compliqué
de de gérer tout ça mais c'est c'est un
peu pour ça aussi qu'on a besoin de
spécialistes dans beaucoup de cas et ça
ça ça a été le premier problème de ce
truc là c'est que de base on était pas
censé le faire on l'a fait contre un est
forcé bon puis aussi parce qu'on aime
bien les animaux hein faut pas se cacher
nous aussi on est sensible àab Disney
c'est
normal mais dans le voilà dans le
meilleur des mondes on l'urait pas le
deuxième problème c'est que derrière il
y a eu plein d'histoire de politique et
et comme d'habitude en conservation je
je sais pas si vous êtes au courant mais
c'est toujours toujours un problème le
domaine de la conservation ne fait pas
exception il y a de la politique de
partout vraiment de partout par exemple
rien que le fait que euh la ville de
Kimberly était plus ou moins en froid
avec certaines entreprises qui du coup
ne relâchaient pas l'eau qu'il fallait
dans le dans le lac c'est une histoire
de
politique qui du coup a impacté les
espèces euh le fait que euh certaines
entreprises certaines unités de
conservation ont essayé de tirer la
couverture à elles lorsqu'elles ont fait
euh des actions pour ces flamands alors
que bah c'est pas du tout elle qui les
faisait par exemple pour juste récupérer
des sous que derrière les autres n'ont
jamais vu par exemple alors je citerai
pas de nom évidemment parce que voilà
mais on a eu des des associations qui
ont décidé que elle lèverrait des fonds
pour les Flamands de de de de
campfdam et puis B il y a jamais rien
qui est arrivé alors on sait qu'elles
ont levé des fonds qu'elles ont fait des
des crowdfunding des trucs des machins
puis bah il y a jamais de sous qui sont
arrivés dans la cagnotte générale en
fait et ça ça c'est pareil c'est c'est
c'est pas cool voilà et c'est aussi une
histoire de politique c'est des gens qui
sont là juste pour le côté financier bon
bah quand tu sais que ça existe voilà ok
mais c'est ça fait toujours un peu mal
au cœur d'autres personnes qui voyaient
aussi leur propre intérêt par exemple on
a eu un vétérinaire alors c'est c'était
c'était un peu triste d'ailleurs d'une
certaine manière mais à Kimberly vous
avez un vétérinaire un vétérinaire qui
qui qui est content d'avoir sa petite
clinique là-bas mais qui se prend un peu
pour
pour le roi de la montagne parce que
évidemment c'est le seul véau du coin et
et c'est lui qui est un peu qui gère un
peu tout ça il a son cabinet médical
enfin il est content d'être dans son
petit truc c'est bien sauf que c'est
c'est un véteau qui qui est un véteau de
campagne normal alors je dis pas que les
véteaux de campagne il sont pas bien au
contraire je respecte beaucoup leur
boulot mais en l'occurrence lui c'était
un cas un peu
particulier parce que lui il était en
train de tenir tête au vétérinaire de
zoo genre la veto euh qui bosse au
niveau international déjà en plus qui
est enseignante dans la meilleure
université veto que tu peux trouver en
Afrique et euh qui est spécialiste des
animaux un peu exotiques un peu spéciaux
avec en plus des collègues qui se
spécialisent dans les oiseaux et cetera
et donc qui était là en tant que euh
agent du gouvernement pour essayer
d'indiquer euh à ceux qui géraient les
Flamands à Kimberly comment il fallait
faire
et et le véau lui lui a carrément le
véau de Kimberly lui a carrément dit il
allait se faire voir
euh il y a un moment où où tu tu peux
quand même reconnaître que la personne
en face de toi a des compétences que tu
n'as pas et que bah voilà il faut quand
même que tu
tu bon non euh donc il y a des gens
comme ça qui qui sont un peu un peu
bizarres aussi et qui il faut travailler
avec et c'est c'est pas toujours simple
tous les
jours
malheureusement donc tout ça c'est c'est
des histoires de politique tout ça c'est
des trucs qui viennent parasiter en fait
tout ce qu'on fait alors je vous ai
montré de jolies images je vous ai
montré le comment ça se passe évolution
du flamament et cetera mais il faut bien
comprendre que derrière il y a encore
toute une couche de de difficultés qui
viennent juste euh parce que on on est
des humains et qu'on travaille les uns
avec les autres et que et que des fois
c'est compliqué très compliqué et qu'on
aimerait si on pouvait juste travailler
avec des animaux mais que c'est pas
possible voilà donc euh c'est c'est en
ça euh que que je vous dis que c'est
c'est c'est pas simple ce genre de chos
et encore une fois les spécialistes sont
là pour une
raison normalement c'est à eux qu'on est
censé faire appel lorsque on veut avoir
quelque chose qui qui se passe qui se
passe bien donc là que ce soit pour le
début où on aurait dû faire appel à un
spécialiste avant de dire ouais on va
récupérer les œufs et puis on va
récupérer 3000 œufs et puis ça va bien
se passer et et finalement être
déborderé avoir besoin d'appeler de
l'aide derrière tout ça ça parasite
votre opération et ça fait que bah les
espèces sont pas forcément sauvées
derrière c'est un peu embêtant sans
compter que on a eu d'autres problèmes
ensite ça faut aussi que je vous le
raconte parce que c'est triste mais
c'est comme ça en fait vous vous dites
bon on a relâché les flamaments c'est
bien du coup ils sont venus mettre plus
de de flamand de de venir grossir la
population générale de Flam en un autour
de Kimberly et en Afrique en général et
c'est quand même vachement
bien oui
mais alors là ça va être je suis désolée
ça va un peu être la douche froide mais
en
gros quasiment aucun de ces flamants
qu'on a relâché n'a survécu deux raisons
à
ça la première on les a élevé en
captivité on a fait de notre mieux pour
qu'ils aient les pattes dans l'eau
maximum tout le temps pour qu'ils
comprennent qu'ils doivent rester les
pattes dans l'eau régulièrement mais
malgré tout ils ont quand même été
élevés bah avec nous N qui avons les
pieds sur terre pas dans l'eau et et
leur premier réflexe dès la première
nuit lorsqu'on les a laissé partir ça a
été de rester sur le rivage et de pas
aller au milieu du lac avec les autres
flamands alors qu'ils auraient dû aller
au milieu du lac avec les autres
flamands pourquoi parce que quand un
flamant va passer la nuit au milieu du
lac bah c'est pour se protéger des
prédateurs en fait ça évite les
caracales ça évite les chiens irant ça
évite les Léopards ça évite tous les
trucs qui peuvent venir le manger
pendant la nuit et et les nôtres bah ils
avaient pas ce réflexe là donc bah ils
se sont fait
bouffer et puis pareil après
euh ceux qui sont pas fait bouffer par
les prédateurs je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que les gens du coin qui
habitent dans les bidonville autour de
Kimberly parce qu'il y en a quelquesuns
aussi c'est l'Afrique hein
malheureusement euh ben ces gens-là en
fait ils ont ils sont en recherche
constante de trucs à manger et on peut
pas leur en vouloir parce que leur mode
de vie est quand même pas facile et ils
ont besoin de protéines aussi hein comme
tout le monde et du coup bah ils ont vu
les Flamands bah ils ont ils sont partis
les manger voilà donc on a des Flamands
qui sont passés à la broche et on le
sait parce qu'on a retrouvé les bagues
après avec des eos qui étaient bien
taillées on avait des fait des entailles
au couteau et tout et s'en fait
manger voilà donc c'est
c'est une ça a été une opération qui a
été inutile en fait donc ça c'est des
millions qui ont été bon on a quelques
flamands quand même qu' ont survécu mais
en règle générale c'est des millions qui
ont été jetés comme ça par les fenêtres
et on aurait pu les utiliser à faire
quelque chose autre parce qu'en plus là
du coup ça a été une urgence on a on a
été obligé de de faire les choses dans
l'urgence parce que bah on avait pas le
choix ils étaient là les Flamands
fallait bien faire quelque chose ou mais
dans ce cas-là tu prépares par pas
suffisamment bien tu fais pas ton
opération correctement alors que
normalement quand tu as le temps de
préparer ton opération tu peux faire les
choses un peu plus de manière un peu
plus raisonné un peu plus réfléchie tu
arrives à mettre en place de nouveaux
protocoles qui fonctionnent bien bah ça
permet vraiment d'avoir des choses qui
soient un peu mieux faites et qui
permettent d'avoir de meilleurs
résultats derrière bah là ça a pas été
le cas c'est des choses qui arrivent
mais ça aurait gagné à ne soit être plus
réfléchi soit à ne pas être fait en
fait voilà donc c'est c'est triste à
dire hein mais c'est une opération qui
je pense a été totalement inutile et
n'aurait n'avait pas lieu d'être alors
vu que c'était une opération inutile
j'espère que vous avez laissé des jeunes
des jeunes enfants à l'école participer
au programme et créer des vocations
contrairement au enchaîne toujours le
contact entre animaux sauvag et le grand
public non parce qu'en fait quand tu
quand tu as des des animaux comme ça qui
sont censés être relâchés dans la nature
déjà d'une tu évite le contact avec plus
Mo au maximum donc bon on les a élevé
comme on a pu mais on a essayé de de pas
avoir trop de mond qui venaient les voir
aussi pour une autre raison c'est qu'en
Afrique du Sud il y a pas mal de vagues
euh avien influenza donc ça ce sont
c'est le virus de la grippe aviaire qui
se balade pas mal en Afrique du Sud qui
est souvent assez présent notamment avec
des poules et ce genre de choses dans
les élevages donc plus tu laisses de
personnes rentrer avoir un contact avec
tes oiseaux plus tu t'exose à la
transmission de ce virus à tes oiseaux
qui sont censés plus tard être relâchés
dans la nature donc tu veux pas que le
virus déjà tue tes oiseaux en captivité
parce que c'est quand même un virus qui
peut être facilement mortel et de deux
tu veux pas non plus que tes oiseaux
soient contaminé et qu'ensuite
lorsqu'ils soit lâchés il balance le
virus avec eux dans la population
sauvage parce que ça tu veux pas que ça
arrive sinon le reste de ta population
sauvage il passe donc ben on pouvait pas
vraiment laisser des gens autres que
ceux qui soignaient vraiment ces oiseaux
là en contact avec donc n on n' pas eu
d'école on n' pas eu de de jeunes qui
sont venus aider et tout et même quand
on avait des volontaires c'est des
volontaires qu'on avait entraîné
nous-mêm euh qui souvent d'ailleurs
était juste là pour le nettoyage parce
que c'est un peu le problème d'un
volontaire c'est que un volontaire il
est bien il est gentil il vient mais inv
volontaire il a pas la capacité euh
forcément de nourrir un oiseau à la
pipette il a pas la capacité de faire la
différence comme je disais tout à
l'heure entre euh l'eusophage et le trou
pour l'attracher euh dans la bouche de
l'oiseau et si jamais il se trompe c'est
un oiseau perdu parce que quand tu
balances de la nourriture dans la
trrachée c'est pas rattrapable
donc voilà
ce les volontaires ils sont ils sont
vraiment très appréciés vraiment mais
généralement on leur donne des tâches
qui sont pas qui sont pas vraiment du
contact avec des animaux purs c'est
c'est surtout des tâches qui vont être
du nettoyage nettoyage général de la
désinfection et peut-être de la
préparation de la
nourriture mais mais si si on arrive à
avoir le temps de les entraîner mais ça
aussi c'est un autre problème c'est que
comme ça on a fait en urgence bah du
coup on avait pas le temps d'entraîner
qui que ce soit non plus j'aurais bien
aimé avoir quelqu'un qui me remplace
régulièrement pour nourrir à la ptitette
et tout parce que quand tu en as 200 à
nourrir comme ça et que tu repis le
processus toutes les 2 heures
ouais tu as bien envie d'avoir 5 minutes
de je vais me poser dans un coin à labas
et puis hein vas-y continue sans moi
mais ben non du coup
voilà donc c'est c'est un peu compliqué
donc généralement on n'essaie pas
d'avoir un contact entre ces animaux
sauvages et le grand public au maximum
il y'y en a pas quand on peut l'hésiter
évidemment euh les goans mazoutés
nettoyés après marénor ont un tour de
survie supérieur a flamament rose
normalement oui parce qu'en fait les
goans mazouté nettoyés après marinoire
de ce que j'en sais tu les gardes un
petit peu en observation le temps que
les plumes se se régénère un peu et que
du coup ils puisse de nouveau avoir ses
plumes waterproof que que tu puisses le
lâcher ensuite s'ils ont pas mangé s'ils
ont pas essayé eux-mêmes de se nettoyer
et qu'ils ont pas ingéré trop de mazout
normalement tu peux les sauver mais
c'est le problème c'est quand il ingère
du mazout ça ça passe pas voilà donc ça
dépend de ce qui s'est passé avec ton
goéan bah c'est ça on aurait pu faire un
élevage de poulet pour nous la
population locale ce serait revenu moins
cher et en plus ce qui aurait été bien
c'est qu'on aurait pu employer les gens
qui sont dans le bidonville pour
s'occuper des poulets donc tu vois c'est
en plus ils auraient eu un job mais là
non donc ça c'est un peu triste c'est un
peu dommage et euh bon B voilà bon après
c'est une opération qui nous a appris
aussi ce qu'il fallait faire et ce qu'il
ne fallait pas faire he c'est et puis ça
a appris aussi au gouvernement
sud-africain ce qu'il fallait faire et
ce qu'il ne fallait pas faire et
j'espère que la prochaine fois ça se
passera mieux mais mais voilà c'est
juste pour vous dire que toutes les
opérration conservation ne se passe pas
forcément bien que des fois il y a des
trucs qui malgré tous les efforts qu'on
peut mettre dedans bah ça ça marche pas
et on fait ce qu'on peut hein mais
c'était parfois vé à l'échec oh je vous
ai pas montré la vidéo Vidéo de Comment
les Flamands mangent c'est vrai que du
coup son commenta ça me fait penser à ça
alors ça c'est des petits flamands donc
là ils ont
entre à peu près un mois et demi alors
là ce que vous voyez sur la vidéo c'est
qu'en fait ils sont en train de taper
sur le sol avec leur papat et et là on
voit bien avec le le bec qui est un peu
retourné alors là ils ont pas le bec
d'adulte complètement mais c'est c'est
quand il était encore petit que j'ai
pris la vidéo mais on commence à voir
déjà qu'ils ont le bec un peu à l'envers
comme ça pour justement choper les
essayer de de filtrer l'eau
[Musique]
et du coup il tape avec les pâtes pour
en fait faire remonter le le substrat et
notamment faire remonter les petits
invertébrés les bactéries trucs comme ça
don il se
[Musique]
nourissent c'est c'est l'instinct donc
ça on n pas eu besoin de leur apprendre
ça ça faire tout
[Musique]
seul
comportement aussi complexe soé c'est
pas si complexe que ça au final parce
que c'est vraiment lié à leur
physiologie donc tu as un bec d'une
certaine manière donc bah tu vas
l'utiliser de cette manière là
contrairement au rechigne toujours le
contact entre animaux sauvag et le grand
public il y il y a deux trois trucs à
dire sur les EAU
effectivement le contact entre animaux
sauvages et personnes du grand public
n'est pas encouragé pour plusieurs
raisons déjà comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure on sait pas trop où est-ce que
le grand public a traîné donc on a pas
envie que transfère des maladies à à nos
oiseaux ou à nos animaux en général euh
quand il y a contact avec les animaux on
essaie de désinfecter évidemment la
personne qui vient et qui a contact
parce qu' il y a quand même des endroits
qui font le contact entre certains
animaux et et le public mais pas tous et
dans ces cas-là on essaie généralement
de faire en sorte que ça se passe le
mieux possible que le public ne chope
pas de maladie au contact de l'animal
parce qu'on sait jamais ça peut arriver
aussi et que l'animal ne chope pas de
maladie au contact du public parce que
ça aussi ça peut arriver et et c'est
pour ça notamment que le contact avec
les singes et extrêmement réglementé et
vous rentrez pas même les soigneurs
animaliers hein s'ils sont malades ils
vont pas s'occuper de leur de leur grand
singe par exemple parce que bah ils sont
tout à fait capables de leur filer leur
r même famille tout ça tout ça donc il y
a déjà cette raison là et puis après il
y a l'autre raison c'est que de plus en
plus c'est c'est très très mal vu c'est
très très mal considéré par beaucoup
d'associations et beaucoup de gens
d'ailleurs de proposer un contact avec
un animal alors ça peut être avec tout
toutes ces histoires de de C fille que
les gens font par exemple avec un tigre
qui a été drogué en arrière-plan je sais
pas quel type d'animal qu'on a qu'on a
attaché ou qu'on a
rendu qu'on a rendu totalement
inoffensif en lui retirant les dents au
les griffes par exemple bref tout ce
genre de chose ça très très très
mauvaise publicité et du coup les os qui
sont vu en train de donner un contact
avec un
animal sauvage à un membre du public
c'est un peu vu
comme comme si était un de ces endroits
qui n'avait finalement qui ne
s'occupaent pas de leurs animaux et que
les animaux étaient juste là pour offrir
un contact avec le grand public et et
gagner des sous avec ça et et ça c'est
des choses que auquels les Z veulent pas
être assimilés ou les aquariums
d'ailleurs parce que c'est pareil et bon
avec raison hein tu t'as pas trop envie
d'être assimilé à ce genre de de
pratique assez assez désagréable c'est
en plus il y a des des nouvelles lois en
des nouvelles lois des nouvelles règles
qui sont sorties au niveau de la la
communauté mondiale des eau et aquarium
World association of aquums qui a sorti
des nouvelles règles sur l'animal
welfare en captivité et notamment sur le
contact avec les animaux et qui
encourage fortement voire même
qui je dirais bien interdit mais
interdire c'est un mot un peu fort quand
même mais qui ne cautionne pas du tout
le contact entre le grand public et les
animaux dans les EAU parce que ils ne
doivent pas être vu comme autre chose
que des animaux sauvages auquels normal
on n'est pas censé avoir accès c'està
dire que ces animaux là c'est pas des
peluches à caressé c'est pas des joujou
on n'est pas censé les toucher tu peux
les regarder de loin si tu veux mais tu
vas pas leur faire un câlin c'est tout
et je suis d'accord avec ça en fait
alors oui c'est vrai que encourager le
contact avec ces animaux là ça permet
aussi d'encourager une certaine relation
entre même pas entre l'animal et la
personne en fait c'est juste la personne
qui touche l'animal on sait que ça
encourage aussi un certain sentiment euh
d'avoir un contact avec un animal comme
ça ça
encourage l'envie de protéger cet animal
parce qu'on a eu un contact assez intime
finalement avec avec cette btile qu'on
aurait jamais pu voir
autrement mais est-ce que c'est
suffisant pour palier à tous les
problèmes est-ce que juste voir l'animal
de loin est-ce que ça suffirait pas à à
t'apprendre que cet animal il est
important ou à t'apprendre que bah oui
il faut respecter la nature ou je ne
sais quoi est-ce que tu peux pas faire
ça sans il y a aussi cette question là
derrière c'est ça c'est au au goût de
chacun après mais je peux pas leur
donner tort là-dessus euh il y a des
raisons derrière cette pratique et je
pense qu'elles sont bonnes aussi avec
les dauphins on n plus le droit de s'en
approcher en Méditerranée au parcils ont
retiré les dauphins et après j'apprends
qu'ils ont coupé les doigts des Flamans
roses pour pas qu'il s'envolle c'est
bien compliqué tout ça oui oui c'est
compliqué c'est très compliqué mais
c'est pour ça que normalement dans
chaque zo et aquarium tu as ce qu'on
appelle un comité d'éthique voire même
au niveau au-dessus tu as un comité
d'éthique qui va justement statuer sur
toutes ces décisions et savoir si
effectivement c'est considéré comme
éthique ou pas et tu as des tas de
règles à respecter tu as des tas de
choses à faire en fonction de la
législation du pays aussi c'est pas
aussi simple que ça et donc en fonction
de de de tout ça ils vont décider
ok on va on va effectivement restreindre
les flamaments on va les garder en
extérieur parce que ça leur offre
peut-être un plus grand parc mettons
mais on va restraindre leur capacité de
mouvement et et du coup ça va permettre
d'avoir de les avoir ici sur le lac sans
avoir besoin de tout grillager ou de
mettre un filet au-dessus ce qui
n'aurait pas été possible par exemple
qu'on aurait plus d'autres comme
solution éthique par exemple si vous
avez des des serpents en captivité vous
les nourrissez avec quoi est-ce que vous
allez utiliser des souris qui sont déjà
surgelé et que vous allez juste remettre
à température ambiante avant de le
donner au serpents sachant que certains
ne les prennent pas certains serpents ne
reconnaissent pas ça ça comme de la
nourriture si l'animal est déjà mort par
exemple ou est-ce que vous allez
autoriser euh vos soigneurs animaliers
qui s'occupent des serpents à filer de
la nourriture vivante à certains
serpents qui justement se laissent
mourir de faim si tu leur donnes pas des
souris vivantes comment est-ce que tu
gères ton truc et là du coup c'est au
comité éthique de
trancher il y a plein de questions comme
ça que le comité éthique doit trancher
hein de manière journalière voilà mais
mais c'est c'est plus complexe que ça en
a l'air en fait et je pense peut-être
qu'on fera une vidéo sur le sujet si ça
vous intéresse parce qu' il y a beaucoup
oup de d'exemples comme ça dont on peut
parler euh bah dans la conservation
aussi on a des comités d'éthique hein
pour décider bah par exemple pour les
Flamands pour décider quand est-ce qu'on
doit les relâcher est-ce que c'est une
bonne idée de les relâcher lesquels
doivent être gardés en captivité ou pas
en fonction de comment ils sont de s'ils
ont des blessures de voilà c'est c'est
aussi une comité d'éthique qui décide de
ça on pas vu beaucoup de selfie avec
flamament c'est parce qu'il en a pas qu
V faire scientifique le méchant grand
qui seend selfique animaux sauvages
je qualifie personne de méchant je sais
très bien que les gens qui font ça ils
comprennent pas ou ils savent pas et
c'est pas c'est pas je juge pas en fait
quand quand Quand tu es dans ce genre de
chos alors là je vous ai pris quelques
vidéos parce que j'ai j'ai peut-être eu
5 minutes ce jour-là pour prendre une
vidéo et que je me suis dit voilà tiens
j'ai immortalisé ça parce que quand même
je les aime bien ces bestioles surtout
quand tu
passes beaucoup de temps à t'en occuper
tu as bien envie quand même de garder un
petit souvenir je prends très rarement
des selfies avec les animaux que que je
soigne en fait parce que ça me vient pas
à l'idée alors j'en ai pris un ou deux
avec des Flamands j'avais mis une photo
sur sur Twitter c'est un des seuls que
j'ai pris je crois c'est c'est c'est la
c'est l'une des seulle photo que j'ai
pris et puis après j'en ai une ou deux
autres où en fait bah les photos que
vous ai montré il y en a une ou deux où
je suis dessus mais c'est parce que
c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui a pris la
photo pour moi enfin pour moi qui a pris
la photo et qui me l'a envoyé après en
tout je réagis pas trop comme ça en fait
moi ce qui m'intéresse surtout c'est la
bestiole me voir avec sur la
photo je je trouve pas que je sois aussi
photogénique en
fait
ça non c'est ça je ça m'intéresse pas
mais mais mais oui dans dans l'absolu je
pourrais prendre mais bah par exemple la
vidéo que vous avez vu où là je
suis voilà mais c'est juste que je me
suis pas pris en selfie avec tout
simplement parce que là on a une une
bestiole qui a
genre 4 4 jours mettons 5 jours
peut-être c'est tellement petit tu le
tiens dans la main comme ça tu as
l'impression que tu vas le casser
et c'est c'est juste tu tu fais pas
n'importe quoi avec en fait et voilà
c'est plus plus dans dans cette optique
là que j'ai pas envie de me prendre en
photo avec parce que tu te dis ouais non
tu vas si si tu fais une bêtise derrière
il y a tous les efforts que tu as mis
dedans qui vont qui vont aussi être
réduit à néant et c'est bah c'est
dommage c'est tout mais c'est pas que je
veux pas c'est pas que je veux pas
prendre de selfie c'est que j'y pense
pas en fait mais j'ai des photos avec
moi et des animaux aussi mais c'est vrai
que comparé au temps que je passe avec
il y a pas beaucoup de selfie de moi
avec ça bah c'est ça tu profite du
moment je profite aussi du fait que je
suis avec l'animal que puis puis quand
tu es avec l'animal tu enfin après c'est
peut-être différent pour les autres je
sais pas mais pour moi je je suis là je
suis à 100 % avec la bestiole parce que
si jamais tu fais une erreur si jamais
tu te plantes c'est la vie de l'animal
que tu mets en danger et ton but c'est
quand même de le sauver donc moi je suis
là j'essaie de de gérer la l'animal du
mieux que je peux j'essaie de gérer les
problèmes autour s'il y en a et puis bah
j'ai pas l'intention de sortir juste le
portable pour prendre un selfie juste
pour j'étais vraiment concentré sur sur
la tâche que tu es en train de faire
voilà c'est tout merci à toutes et à
tous d'avoir suivi cette vidéo on se
retrouve très bientôt sur twitch ou sur
Youtube pour de nouvelles aventures avec
des
[Musique]
plumes